Oh
hi welcome to the first ColdFusion video
of 2016 let's start the year with a bang
in the form of rocket blasts throughout
the ages human civilizations have always
looked up at the Stars and wondered
what's out there
over the centuries we've learned a great
deal about space but have had very
little advancement in the ways of
exploring it as time progressed the
power and capabilities of technology
increased but space travel was largely
left behind by the end of the 20th
century and into the 21st century space
travel was still complicated expensive
and worst of all run totally by
government there's just too much red
tape waiting to snag the fresh ideas of
scientists and physicists leading to a
pre style industry until now that is one
man who chooses to dream big has started
to change all of this that one man is
Elon Musk and his big dream is SpaceX
in this video we'll learn all about
SpaceX how and why have started its
achievements and future plans let's get
straight into it so first up why and how
did it get started SpaceX or space
exploration technology corporation was
founded in 2002 by Elon Musk the CEO of
Tesla Motors and the co-founder of
PayPal
SpaceX is main goal is to create
technologies to reduce space
transportation costs and enable the
colonization of Mars Y space why are you
what do you think it's important for us
to be sure at home access to low Earth
orbit with with SpaceX it's trying to
help solve the kind of spacefaring
problem I mean I think that a future
where we're a spacefaring civilization
and a multi-planet species is very
exciting inspiring awesome future and in
order for that to happen we've got to
dramatically improve the cost of
spaceflight
if we can keep improving the cost of
spaceflight then eventually that trend
is in the right direction it could be
leading to a city on Mars and certainly
along the way a lot of activity and low
Earth orbit and the moon and lots of
other exciting things eelain's initial
vision was to create relatively
inexpensive reusable rockets that could
have travel characteristics similar to
current commercial airlines that is you
can send a ship out to space with cargo
passengers or any payload re-enter and
land back on earth and be ready for the
next flight within hours in the early
2000s Elon approached members of
Russia's space program three times to
gain access to a refurb Russian rocket
in order to start his practical space
dream
unfortunately for Elon the deal ended up
falling through but after this he
realized something
he didn't need the Russians or anyone
else because rocket technology had more
or less stayed the same since the 1960s
so for any real progress to be made
there needed to be a whole new way of
doing things
a better way not many people believed in
private space travel so Ellen was going
to have to do most of this by himself
and all from his pocket so I had to come
up with low-cost ways to produce engines
the primary structured electronics to
the launch operation as well as run the
company with with with very little
overhead in the end he managed to reduce
the cost of building rocket greatly by
streamlining the process into an
economically viable territory think of
it much like how Henry Ford made the
automobile cheap to manufacture
about 80% of all parts from any SpaceX
rocket are made in-house by SpaceX
themselves okay so that's all nice but
really what's the big deal
well firstly eelain's methods are
drastically cheaper let me explain
traditionally for NASA to launch
anything into space just once
can cost anywhere from 100 to 260
million dollars for the SpaceX program a
falcon 9 rocket would cost about 57
million dollars to make but it is
reusable and burns about 200 thousand
dollars worth of fuel per launch so
pretty much after paying for the rocket
which is half the price of just a
regular launch anyway you will be
spending a few hundred thousand instead
of about 200 million per launch this is
a quantum leap in cost savings this is
one of the reasons why there's so much
excitement around SpaceX all right so
it's cheaper but what else has SpaceX
done
what other breakthroughs are there well
let's take a look in 2008 SpaceX became
the first privately funded liquid
propelled rocket to reach orbit in 2010
they were the first privately funded
company to successfully launch orbit and
recover a spacecraft 2012 the first
private company to send a spacecraft to
the International Space Station 2013
SpaceX delivered a satellite marking the
company's first delivery beyond Earth
orbit SpaceX has flown six missions to
the International Space Station and
finally on December 21st 2015
SpaceX successfully returned a first
stage booster back to the ground
the very first such accomplishment by an
orbit capable rocket the main purpose of
this mission was to put 11 satellites in
orbit for SpaceX s customer or comm
Penny Ling soo Miah fun
from the
bad
oh he want the [ __ ] his life
- procedural of about walk
the completion of this mission marks the
first major advancement in space
technology in over 30 years
a true milestone event proving the
endless possibilities of
entrepreneurship this achievement wasn't
without failure though the previous
launch attempt failed due to a faulty
steel strut but with all of that being
said I think the biggest deal and the
most amazing thing about SpaceX
is actually how Elon Musk approached the
challenges that came his way
when Elon started SpaceX he came from a
software engineering and business role
in PayPal and obviously vastly different
world to rocket science how is he ever
going to learn about rocket science to
build a company based around it the
answer read books and learn rocket
science according to Elon Musk's
biography that's exactly what he did
here's a quote musk felt comfortable
standing up for his positions and
directing teams of coders at PayPal but
at SpaceX he had to pick things up on
the job musk initially relied on
textbooks to form the bulk of his
rocketry knowledge but as SpaceX hired
one brilliant person after another musk
realized that he could tap into their
stores of knowledge he would trap an
engineer in the SpaceX Factory and set
to work grilling them about a type of
valve or specialized material one SpaceX
engineer Kevin Brogan states I thought
at first that he was challenging me to
see if I knew my stuff then I realized
he was trying to learn things he would
quiz you until he had learned 90% of
what you know and quote
okay so almost at the end of the video
but before we finish water Ilan's goals
here my supposed to reduce the cost of
space payloads by a factor of 10 to
about $1,000 per kilogram or less in
June of 2015
SpaceX asked the federal government to
begin testing for a project that aims to
build a constellation of 4,000
satellites capable of beaming the
internet down to the entire globe
including remote regions
which currently do not have internet
access Ellen must long-term vision for
the company is to develop technology and
resources suitable for the human
colonization of Mars
he hopes to send humans to Mars by 2030
and he has expressed interest in living
there someday so far this seems like the
stuff of science fiction but how close
are we actually to getting people in
space well it actually might be pretty
soon spacex has used its dragon
spacecraft to make uncrewed cargo runs
to the international space station and
this has proved its basic vessel space
worthiness the company is scheduled to
begin manned runs to the International
Space Station in 2017 so there you have
it that's the story of SpaceX and what
they are up to now it's incredible that
one man and his idea could cut into and
disrupt possibly the hardest industry on
this planet just as a final thought I
want to leave you with this here's a
quote from Jim Cantrell who was part of
the founding team at SpaceX with Elon
Musk quote so I am going to suggest that
Elon is not successful because his
vision too grand not because he is
extraordinarily smart not because he
works incredibly hard all those things
are true but the one major important
distinction that sets him apart is his
inability to consider failure it is
simply not in his thought process it
doesn't matter if he's going up against
the banking system with PayPal are going
up against the entire aerospace industry
with SpaceX while going up against the
US auto industry with Tesla he cannot
imagine not succeeding and this is a
very critical trait that ultimately
leads him to success what separated us I
believe was his lack of being able to
conceive failure I know this because
this is how he parted ways of SpaceX we
got to the point where I could not see
SpaceX succeeding and walked away but he
stayed with the project and succeeded I
have 25 years of building space hardware
and he had none at the time so much for
experience and
so that's just something to think about
okay on that note that's the end of this
video I'd like to know your thoughts on
SpaceX and what they're doing at the
moment if you're new here feel free to
subscribe if you want to watch more cool
stuff hang around for the next 10
seconds and follow the prompts on your
screen anyway this has been to gogo and
you're been watching cold fusion thanks
for watching I'll catch you again soon
for the next video
cheers guys cold fusion it's me thinking
you